This lecture is about the paradigmatic
relation discovery.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about how to discover a particular kind
of word Association called paradigmatic
relations.
By definition, 2 words are
paradigmatically related if they share
similar contexts.
Namely, they occur in similar positions
in text.
So naturally, our idea for discovering
such relation is to look at the context
of each word and then try to compute
the similarity of those contexts.
So here's an example of context of
word Cat.
Here I have taken the word cat out of
the context.
And you can see we are seeing some
remaining words in the sentences that
contain cat.
Now we can do the same thing for
another word like a dog.
So in general we would like to capture
such a context and then try to assess
the similarity of the context of cat
and the context of a word like dog.
So now the question is, how can we
formally represent the context and then
define the similarity function?
So first we note that the context
actually contains a lot of words.
So they can be regarded as a pseudo
document.
An imaginary document.
But there are also different ways of
looking at the context.
For example, we can look at the word
that occurs before the word cat.
We can call.
We can call this context left1
context.
So in this case you will see words
like my, his or big, a, the, etc.
These are the words that can occur to
the left of the world cat.
So we say my cat, his cat big cat.
a cat etc.
Similarly, we can also collect the
words that occur right after the word
cat.
We can call this context right1.
And here we see words eats, ate, is, has,
etc.
Or more generally, we can look at the
all the words in the window of text
around the word cat. Here
let's say we can take a window of eight
words around the world cat.
We call this context
Window8
Now of course, you can see all the
words from left or from right, and so
we have a bag of words in general to
represent the context.
Now, such a word based representation
would actually give us interesting way
to define the perspective of measuring
the similarity.
Because if you look at just the
similarity of left1, then we'll see
words that share just the words in the
left context and we kind of ignore the
other words that are also in the general
context.
So that gives us one perspective to
measure the similarity.
And similarly, if we only use the right1
context will capture the
similarity from another perspective.
Using both left1 and right1,
ofcourse would allow us to capture the
similarity with even more strict
criteria.
So in general, context may contain
adjacent words like eats and my that you
see here or non-adjacent words like
Saturday, Tuesday or some other words
in the context.
And this flexibility also allows us to
measure the similarity similarity in
some other different ways.
Sometimes this is useful as we might
want to capture similarity based on
general content that would give us
loosely related paradigmatic relations,
whereas if you use only the words
immediately to the left and to the
right of the world, then you likely
will capture words that are very much
related by
their syntactical categories and
semantics.
So the general idea of discovering
paradigmatic relations is to compute
the similarity of context of two words.
So here for example, we can measure the
similarity of cat and dog based on the
similarity of their contexts.
In general, we can combine all kinds of
views of the context and so the
similarity function is in general
combination of similarities on
different contexts.
And of course we can also assign
weights to these different similarities
to allow us to focus more on particular
kind of context, and this would be
naturally application specific, but again
here
that main idea for discovering
paradigmatically related words is to
compute the similarity of their
context.
So next, let's see how we exactly
compute these similarity functions.
Now to answer this question it's useful
to think of bag of words representation
as vectors in the vector space model.
Now those of you who have been familiar
with information retrieval or text
retrieval techniques would realize that
vector space model has been used
frequently for modeling documents and
queries for search.
But here we also find it convenient to
model the context of a word for
paradigmatically relation discovery.
So the idea of this approach is to view
each word in our vocabulary as defining
one dimension in high dimensional space
so we have N words in total in the
vocabulary.
Then we have N dimensions as
illustrated here.
And on the bottom you can see
frequency vector representing a
context.
And here we see when eats occured five
times in this context,
ate occurred three times etc.
So this vector can then be placed in
this vector space model.
So in general, we can represent a
pseudo document or context of cat as
one vector.
d1.
An another word dog might give us a
different context, so d2.
And then we can measure the similarity
of these two vectors.
So by viewing context in the vector
space model, we convert the problem of
paradigmatic relations discovery into
the problem of computing the vectors
and their similarity.
So the two questions that we have to
address is first
how to compute each vector, that is,
how to compute the xi or yi?
And the other question is, how do you
compute the similarity?
Now in general there are many
approaches that can be used to solve
the problem, and most of them are
developed for information retrieval.
And
they have been shown to work well for
matching a query vector and a document
vector, but we can adapt the many of
the ideas to compute the similarity of
context documents for our purpose here.
So let's first look at the one possible
approach,
where we try to measure the similarity
of context based on the expected
overlap of words and we call this EOWC.
So the idea here is represent
a context by award vector where each
word has a weight that is equal to the
probability that a randomly picked
word from this document vector is this
word.
So in other words.
xi is defined as the normalized count
of word wi in the context.
And this can be interpreted as a
probability that you would actually
pick this word from d1 if you
randomly pick the word.
Now of course these xi's will sum to 1
because they are normalized
frequencies.
And
this means the vector is actually
probability distribution over words.
So,
the vector d2 can be also computed in
the same way.
And this would give us then two
probability distributions representing
two contexts.
So that addresses the problem how to
compute the vectors?
Next, let's see how we can define
similarity in this approach.
Well, here we simply define the
similarity as a dot product of two
vectors and this is defined as the sum
of the products of all the
corresponding elements of the two
vectors.
Now it's interesting to see that this
similarity function actually has a nice
interpretation.
And there is this dot product
infact gives us the probability that two
randomly picked words from the two
contexts
are identical that means if we try to
pick a word from one context and try to
pick another word from another context,
we can then ask the question, are they
identical?
If the two contexts are very similar,
then we should expect that we frequently
will see the two words picked from the
two contexts are identical.
If they are very different then the
chance of seeing identical words being
picked from the two contexts would be
small.
So this intuitively makes sense for
measuring similarity of contexts.
Now you might want to also take a look
at the exact formulas and see why this
can be interpreted as the probability
that two randomly picked words are
identical.
So if you just stay at the formula
to check what's inside this sum then
you will see,
basically in each case it gives us the
probability that we'll see overlap on a
particular word, wi and where xi gives us
the probability that will pick this
particular word from d1 and
yi
gives us the probability of picking
this word from d2 and when we pick the
same word from the two contexts then we
have identical
pick.
Alright, so that's one possible
approach.
EOWC expected overlap of words in
context.
Now, as always, we would like to assess
whether this approach it would work well.
Now, of course, ultimately we have to
test the approach with real data and
see if it gives us really semantically
related words really give us a
paradigmatic relations.
But analytically, we can also analyze
this formula little bit.
So first, as I said, it does make sense
right?
because this formula will give a higher
score if there is more overlap between
the two contexts.
So that's exactly what we want.
But if you analyze the formula more
carefully, then you also see there
might be some potential problems.
And specifically there are two
potential problems. First it
might favor matching one frequent
term very well over matching more
distinct terms, and that is because in
the dot product, if one element has a
high value and this element is shared
by both context and it contributes a
lot to the overall sum.
And it might indeed make the score
higher than in another case where the
two vectors actually have a lot of
overlap in different terms, but each
term has a relatively low frequency.
So this may not be desirable.
Of course, this might be desirable in
some other cases, but in our case we
should intuitively prefer a case where
we match more different terms in the
context so that we have more confidence
in saying that the two words indeed
occur in similar context.
If you only rely on one term and that's
a little bit
questionable.
It may not be robust.
The second problem is that it treats
every word equally, so
if you match a word like the, and
match was, it would be the same as
matching on the word like eats.
But intuitively we know matching the
isn't really surprising because the
occurs everywhere, so matching the is
not as such
a strong evidence as matching a word
like eats
which doesn't occur frequently.
So this is another problem of this
approach.
In the next lecture, we're going to
talk about how to address these
problems.